le parti québécois estime que philippe
couillard aurait pu payer de l'impôt
québec durant son séjour en arabie
saoudite
il le savait que comme étrangers il ne
paierait pas d'impôts en arabie saoudite
mais il aurait pu garder ses comptes
ouverts ici au québec
transférer l'argent de son salaire en
arabie saoudite et payer de l'impôt
comme tout le monde
vérification faite on ne paie pas
d'impôt en arabie saoudite
si monsieur couillard avait durant son
séjour là-bas garder un compte au québec
et qu'il y avait déposé son salaire
comme le suggère le pq l' agence du
revenu aurait sans doute conclut qu'il
avait conservé un lien de résidence avec
le canada et monsieur couillard aurait
en effet payer de l'impôt au québec mais
en quittant pour travailler à l'étranger
tout individu a la possibilité de
devenir un non résident sur le plan
fiscal et de ne pas payer d'impôt au
canada pour être reconnus comme étant
non résidents par l' agence du revenu
il faut couper tous les liens avec le
canada ça veut dire par exemple vendre
sa maison et ses meubles ne laissait au
pays ni conjoint ni personne à charge
l' agence du revenu peut aussi vérifier
si vous avez bien renoncer à votre
permis de conduire et si vous avez bien
fermer vos comptes bancaires au canada